alors maintenant on va faire une petite
interview et c'est normal pour un marin
une petite interview on ne bouge pas
bon alors une petite interview à peine
d'alors le plus le mois notent ils ce
que vous préférez dans le bateau dans le
bateau dans la machine on devait faire
du bateau ont préféré les surfs à 25
noeuds sous pleine lune ça c'est
fabuleux
voilà les traders les 26 et saint-céré
c'est fantastique c'est ce que vous
détestez dans le bateau ce que je
déteste dans le bateau c'est justement
quand quand on casse du matériel stérile
parce qu'à part on se prépare toute
l'année avec toute une équipe et où et
quand on casse du matériel c1 c'est un
échec quoi c'est très dur c'est le
koïfhus interrompu par exemple le plus
grand bien mais deux c'est que ça existe
avant que la pilule c'est a pas connu ça
avant arnaud avant que l'accusé avait
des couilles tu si le terme tu que vous
connaissez vous je suis encore du temps
et la méthode ogino est alors le plus
grand le plus grand lui connaît le plus
grand moment de votre vie
en tout cas des grands moments de
bonheur sur le hobie cat c'était quand
on a traversé l'atlantique à 20 m et et
c'est vrai que de dévaler ces vagues la
plaine pleine vitesse c'était absolument
féerique quoi c'était au niveau de
l'adrénaline j'ai rarement connu aussi
fort et le pire moment de notre vie on
ça a été par exemple à la rencontre avec
un cargo en plein centre de plein face
avec un k way la nuit comme ça vous
dormez puis d'un seul coup en plus
j'étais sur le pont les cargos
maintenant sont tellement long que
finalement on n'entend pas se dire que
quand on est à l'étrave du bateau on
n'entend pas le moteur et donc j'ai
longé l'ensemble du cargo et donc c'est
un cargo qui était vide et à la sortie
donc j'ai vu les hélices qui sortait à
moitié de l'eau et heureusement le main
en fait m'a empêché de passer sous la
sous la voûte du cargo à l'arrière et
deux passes et ce dans les hélices ah
oui c'était une belle
c'est le pire moment ça benbouzid
d'ailleurs une phrase de vous quand on
peut tous inspiré parfois on croit être
à bout on arrive à trouver une énergie
incroyable
c'est vrai c'est ce qui m'intéresse dans
ce lot dans la course en solitaire
d'ailleurs c'est pas du tout chez des
deux seuls ce qui est plutôt studieux
qui avait passé mais c'est justement
d'aller chercher des forces intérieures
qu'on a chacun d'entre nous
l'utiliserons sommes pas dans la vie de
tous les jours parce qu'on n'a pas
besoin en fait qu'est-ce qui vous plaît
le plus dans la vie c'est quoi les gens
nous y rencontre le vibrer jusqu'à vous
et moi tout ce qui est justement le
contraire l'hypocrisie le chercher du
pognon auprès des sponsors savez c'est
dur selon quoi vous vous appuyez genre
de problème alors que tu faisais c'est
pas facile c'est vrai que c'est pas
facile c'est l'inconvénient des sports
mécaniques en fait c'est 10 sport
coûteux et pour s'exprimer on a besoin
de matériel et donc de partenaires pour
voilà alors que michel est là que son
talent pour pour pouvoir s'exprimer vous
aime beaucoup mais on s'aime bien les
réformes la suivait plus sexy en vous
laurent bourgnon ou joker
vous savez bien servir j'ai pas là qu'il
faut que j'en sais que vous avez de
moins sexy alors je viens quand on fait
des métiers comme ça des choses aussi
passionnante avec autant de coeur
on ne peut être que je vais admirer ces
gens sont obligatoirement aimerait
l'avoir de motion aulas
moi ya pas une classe bateau là non moi
j'aurais moi aussi des coups de
téléphone sur le gâteau on a un
téléphone satellite
un vrai aussi qu'on a le fax il m'a
l'air un peu moins drôle même si on peut
avoir sa femme au téléphone tous les
soirs qu'est ce que tu fais une jeune
fille très chaud mieux de l'atlantique
sur c'est sûr que tu es sage sans bien
sûr je suis sage et nous on est obligé
de se faire la cuisine le menacer aux
états unis pendant farrell ans que
mademoiselle alonso vrai quelqu'un qui
est prêt à tout cas bon maintenant alors
merci on va rallumer la lumière concert
mon cher serge khalfon très vite